yeah fluent welcome to this video please
playing PLO grinder so to do we get four
nights okay maybe I had this against in
earlier game who
I think the soon Wow
okay and probably shouldn't think for
too long I think 98 I had on the Bourdon
in some earlier game that looks a bit
strange I just a text apart anyway how
does he untangle all that what you want
all this pieces here 97 and then is out
for 98 you can do that soon I still feel
I should do this move should make this
move I mean that that's good control
here on the dark squares I 98 maybe had
anyway so just protect the f-pawn just
kind of curious how we untangles this
yeah this is possible but you still not
still don't quite see how he's getting
his pieces developed
quite sure where to put the bishop here
and now I can I can take and play Knight
the fight again I just wonder if I play
the Queen c7 how the seam address that
but this is also just good let's let's
play it not not spend more time
okay so just double on the default then
maybe he can untangle this way
okay this threatens to shake a play
night at 5:00 and he cannot move the
bishop at the moment that's annoying
okay it still moves the vigil okay that
move looks a bit counterintuitive I
dream the piece blank realize that that
tell me that that did not look like a
good opening position somehow let's have
a look I think this is a line that they
usually play 98 and this I had on the
board once and was okay I mean for black
I think it was reasonably okay it's not
something that I mean I would be in 2d
astok about from the black perspective
but it looked fairly playable this looks
difficult to play I mean Queen g3 makes
sense
I'm keeping very nice advantage here as
well
yeah Bishop b5 I considered but I wasn't
sure because when it looks very nice
with the Queen yet okay I didn't he
didn't consider
smooth and also very one-sided I'm now
but I'm just keeping the pressure with
like I played in the game just a very
convenient position and the problem is a
little bit you still don't know how to
untangle this the engine suggests a six
after after this it gets very difficult
I'm threatening to take and play 95 so
if he does absolutely nothing
check ed wins and he cannot move the
bishop so what move to your player the
engine wants to play this one okay
f4 a6 a vennett also rots in jail with
this and it wasn't a good opening a
thing for black okay guys thanks for
watching